oggi è quel giorno lo sentono percepisco
nell'aria ma niente nessuno potrà
rovinare la mia giornata è soprattutto
la mia pace interiore
sai che qua cosa il fidanzato di
federica le ha chiesto di sposarla ma
com'è possibile sarà riempito di corna
ma pure giulia ora giulia se pure giulia
si può pure lui assist ma sarà per soldi
è possibile che sia per amore
ok marina san valentino un giorno
tossico per te ma tu ce la puoi fare
adesso vai a farti una bella doccia con
un po di musica
vedrai che recupererà in tutte le tue
energie positive
vediamo cosa c'è di bello in una
giornata così speciale come quella di
san valentino mentre la maggior parte di
voi sta festeggiando amoreggiando per il
proprio partner
noi vogliamo tener compagnia anche ai
meno fortunati si sto parlando di coloro
che oggi sono soli come dei cani si si
hai capito bene cara sei sola come un
cane e non c'è neanche più zia maria
latella della famiglia farti compagnia
nel club delle single perché anche lei
al mese fidanzata ma non piangere tesoro
affronta la realtà e il 14 febbraio sei
sola la sola ma solana solana solana
sola ma solo sopravvivere a san
valentino
se sei single
non ti demoralizzare si positiva esci
con le tue amiche e ricorda domani è un
altro giorno 1 sotto non pensarci prima
è mia ma tramite la ragione della mia
vita
amo che fai è stato ci vediamo no ho
capito che sei fidanzata non è che stare
con lui tutto il giorno cioè sommato
migliore amica no va bene non sa amare
chi non sa se lenta stasera festeggiamo
il fatto di essere single e vivere se
scherzando
cioè lui che ha chiesto di uscire per la
prima volta già un san valentino
un primo appuntamento a san marino ma
dai ma che roba trash mando a dire mi
vedete un'altra volta e si come no
amo amo mi senti ma grazie per la
solidarietà che le mie amiche mi voglio
però guardiamo il lato positivo
non devo spendere soldi per fare il
regalo al mio lui così risparmio per
fare tanti regali votatissimo
riscrivermi ex tantissima eight
come stai
oddio online utile visualizzato oddio
cito cioè visualizzato se non mie
risposte
basto io mi arrendo solo una zitto e non
a san valentino non è mio ma perché stai
urlando dirvi che sei triste perché sei
single a san valentino
devi amare te stessa amati
la tua felicità non deve dipendere dagli
altri cuore mio mamma
hai perfettamente ragione non ho bisogno
di nessuno che mi ami perché
l'importante è che io ami me stessa
anzi adesso sai che cosa facciamo vengo
di laici vediamo bel film insieme che
dici spicca poi san valentino ma festa
mamma forse cambiato idea se sì perché
voglio riuscire
anzi ai 6 c che voglio preparare